une salle pour les arts plastiques une
pour l'informatique ou une autre pour
les chorales la région a misé sur le
confort et le développement artistique
avec cette nouvelle maison de l'étudiant
plus de huit millions d'euros ont été
investis
le terrain a été fournie par
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et la ville de guyancourt
si l'aménagement de cet espace de 1732
mètre carré n'est pas encore terminée
les étudiants peuvent déjà en profiter
je trouve ça vraiment très jolie fin
c'est tout nouveau c'est bien et récits
très moderne pour nous les jeunes je
pense que vraiment ça peut aller très
très cool sans bâtiment
je sais pas encore tout ce qu'il
contient mais en tout cas ce qui est
vécu c'est que il sent le bois
donc ça c'est plutôt agréable et
j'espère qu'il est qu'il a des bonnes
normes écologiques et c'est cool quoi
les associations elles aussi sont ravis
de l'ouverture des locaux elle imagine
déjà se développer les services de
l'université pourront travailler en
partenariat avec elle aussi bien pour
l'accès à l'emploi que pour la
prévention médicale ou bien le lien
visibilité auprès des étudiants qui
savent enfin qu'il existe un service
médical parce qu'ils nous voient
et puis sont rencontrés potentiellement
chaque jour dépendamment des dédicaces
au calme comme des convoqués c'est
l'espace consultation et information qui
est véritablement un lieu cosy et
professionnels ou les étudiants pourront
venir chercher donc des informations sur
les stages et la professionnalisation
l'ouverture officielle de la maison de
l'étudiant aura lieu le 22 septembre en
présence notamment de valérie pécresse
présidente de la région ile de france
le guichet unique d'inscription sera lui
ouvert dès le début du mois